The Joe Rogan experience.
If you're lucky,
like we were talking about a hundred years.
you get to a hundred years.
I'm 51 I'm halfway there,
right?
If I'm lucky,
if everything works out perfect and it probably isn't,
let's be honest,
beat the shit out of my body.
Right?
So it's probably not going to make more to make it to be 102 I'll see what's up.
I do because I,
I'm a,
I'm a science nerd.
I'm,
I'm fascinated by all these three d printed hearts and all this shit.
I want to see what the fuck they can do.
I really think,
and talking to guys like David Sinclair and all these anti aging specialist,
I think they're on the verge of being able to reverse aging that they're
treating aging like it's a disease,
like it's a disease at the cellular level instead of accepting it and that like,
wow,
you get older,
hey,
you're going to have to accept,
you can't do as much by is not going to work as well.
Why?
Maybe that's not the case.
Maybe if they can correct certain things about the human body,
maybe they can correct that.
And I think it's very likely that in the future,
I don't think that's an insurmountable a situation.
I think they're gonna be able to correct what happens to your body when it ages,
the deterioration that's caused by the aging process.
Your body produces less hormones,
your body starts to slow down or Alzheimer's,
all these different things.
I think they're gonna be able to correct those things.
Wow.
The problem with that is then what?
We're going to live forever.
You gotta be happy living forever.
Like what if when you die,
it's amazing.
What if when you die,
there really is a heaven.
You really,
really do go to some spectacular dimension filled with love and peace and
happiness,
and there's no emotions like we think about here.
There's no fear.
There's not none of the things that hold people back.
None of the anxiety and the [inaudible] is just consciousness and love and then
you're wasting your time.
You're just trying to stay alive,
taking pills to live to be a million
boy.
You open up big eggs can of worms.
Right.
I will tell you,
um,
Joe,
without a shadow of a doubt,
none whatsoever.
Death is not the end.
You don't think so?
I know,
I know too.
How do you know,
cause I've been dead,
right?
Yes,
I've been there.
What,
what about that experience cemented in your head?
MMM,
when I was,
like I said,
it was the most peaceful.
Um,
and,
and I,
I don't feel like it was the most peace,
most restful,
most I was,
I woke up laughing.
I was,
yeah.
Yeah.
My wife tells me I was overjoyed.
You woke up laugh.
Yeah,
I was over to you remember anything about what happened when you blacked out a
street at the time as an extremely peaceful,
extreme.
I didn't have a worry extremely too.
And I was not a sad at all.
You know,
I was overjoyed,
very happy,
very peaceful and it erased any fear that I might have had and I,
and any fear of dying is gone.
I don't feel that at all.
It.
So I made,
maybe that's why I didn't want to live to be a hundred,
cause I mean I wouldn't mind visiting that place again,
man.
It was so much peace so much and it wasn't like,
you know,
um,
this is,
you know,
I'm just in the ground.
I'm a and I'm not a plant,
uh,
just dirt,
you know,
I know that I'm in a very comfortable place and,
and you know,
I wouldn't mind visiting again.
I wouldn't mind.
So definitely I hold no fear.
And so when I say that it's,
it's definitely not the end.
You're,
I believe that your soul,
you know,
so people have a different name for consciousness of whatever is definitely
eternal.
And then hers.
How else could you have these feelings or emotions or you know,
they had that,
that sort of comfort,
the feeling of comfort and being in the right place if something didn't continue
because my life,
my life was gone,
the sm life,
my,
my bodies,
you know,
gone,
it was gone.
Flat line did what if I told my doctor that died?
And he said,
no,
actually it's called some kind of Paul's or some shit like that.
And I'm saying,
look,
if the pause lasted doc,
I wouldn't be talking to him.
So I call it appalls.
I go,
well,
during that Paul's,
I was dead.
So,
uh,
it's,
it was a wonderful feeling.
Well,
I think with a guy like you that's so physical and you've been so physical your
whole life,
the big fears to not be able to take care of yourself or move,
like that's what we're talking about when you talk about being a hundred,
like having someone wipe your ass and take care of you.
Like that's the big fear.
It's not death that it's peaceful,
it's the end.
But the big fear is the deterioration of the physical body to the point where
it's just painful.
Everything's painful and you can't go anywhere.
He can't count on yourself.
Yeah.
It's,
uh,
it's very peaceful,
but I definitely don't think it's the end.
I think it's the beginning.
Yeah.
And that's a,
it's an overwhelming feeling like I had,
I was able to peek over into the other side and that it's definitely assurance
that it's not the end and that there is something else on the other side,
have that assurance is able to pick it,
just peek it.
Well,
I think we all have this feeling that we are something other than our body.
Most definitely.
I mean,
I,
I have that feeling like I feel like there's like a little ball of energy in
there that moves this thing around.
You're right.
But that's what it feels like.
It always feels like that.
Yeah.
That's what I,
I've always rejected the label atheist.
Like people say,
are you religious?
I'm like,
I was,
when I was a little kid I had to go to Catholic school and I,
you know,
I did all that jazz,
but my parents when I grew up were hippies.
After that,
my mom split up from my dad.
My mom checked up with my stepfather who was a,
he's a hippie and there was no,
no church after that.
But I'm not an atheist.
I'm not,
I don't know.
Like,
I don't believe anybody that says they know what life is or what life means or
what happens when you die.
I want to hear your opinions.
I want to hear your thoughts,
but you don't know.
And anybody that says they know what happens when they die.
I know what happens when I die.
It'll be black and and cold.
And that is the end.
And just like there was nothing before,
there'll be nothing at the end.
And like you don't know that you're just saying that there is no god.
How do you say that?
Well,
one day,
what have you stand in front of God or uh,
in,
in God's presence,
in some nonphysical form.
And then you're,
you're weeping and your arrogance and s say stating that there's no higher
power.
Like it might be the,
the universe itself might be God.
I mean,
we don't know anything.
You,
we are strange little monkey people living on this fucking planet,
making things that alter our environment and moving around,
drive and fly and talking to each other,
talking shit.
But at the end of the day,
you're only aware of what you've experienced and when you don't know,
that's like when people have had,
I've,
I've talked to several friends at vet near death experiences.
Um,
a very good friend of mine,
she,
she was in a car accident and she had a very similar thing where she said it was
so peaceful.
Yeah.
She said,
you know,
they got,
I think that got rear ended and like really banked up and when it felt like she
was going to die,
she felt so peaceful.
It's so true.
True.
Yeah.
I think a lot of people that,
uh,
have come that close to dying,
are,
a lot of them are going to say the same thing,
that they have no fear of death anymore.
It's,
it's he raised and,
uh,
you,
you put,
you also have the feeling that you know,
that this existence on earth when your physical body is Stephanie,
not the end.
The way she describes it as exactly the way you do.
She's my manager and you know,
I talk to her all the time.
The way she describes things is essentially exactly how you did that.
It's just so peaceful.
Just felt,
just felt peaceful.
Yeah.
But not a,
you know,
like
black people who don't believe in back there.
You're,
by the way,
let me think.
Let me say I'm not either.
Yeah.
I was raised super religious in a super religious home by uh,
uh,
a Pentecostal,
heaven or hell brimstone and fire and brimstone preacher.
And they do the tongues.
Oh yes.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Shout and uh,
speaking of times,
everything,
everything.
Wow.
Everything was a sin all summer.
Every,
oh,
dancing.
Dancing was listening to rock and roll music.
Oh yeah.
Everything was us in.
So I think that's really what drove me away from being a religious person.
I'm definitely not,
I always say I'm a man of faith.
I have a tremendous amount of faith,
but faith and religion to two different things.
A lot of people confuse them.
Yeah.
They,
they talk about them as being the same,
but they are definitely not a religious man.
Maids and you know,
a set of rules in Mexico,
we're going to be this.
And if you want to be this religion,
then you're gonna have to go by these rules.
Yeah.
And it's,
it's,
it's all man made,
but faith is not man me and so I'm a tremendous man of faith,
but not religion.
Yeah.
Some would say that like you're a spiritual person.
That's like a thing that gets thrown around today.
Like I'm not religious,
but I'm spiritual.
People say that a lot.
Like what does that mean?
No one really knows.
It's a strange sort of definition,
but I feel what you're saying.
Like there's something more to this.
There's something more to this than just tissue and bone and blood moving on.
This rock that's traveling through the universe.
There's something more,
there's something,
there's some,
and maybe it's just something more for us,
but the beauty of friendship and love and family,
like those things are intense,
beautiful emotional experiences that I,
I don't,
I don't know.
They seem to transcend just regular life itself.
They seem to have a,
there was a higher power to them,
a higher beauty to them.
I think that's one of the things that we like when we see people doing something
really great.
We love seeing people accomplish things cause we we love,
we liked seeing people succeed.
We like seeing people like that have doubts and and something almost
insurmountable and incredibly difficult in front of them and then they,
they overcome and it gives us all hope and it gives us all like this
inspiration,
this feeling.
We're connected in some sort of very,
very strange way that I think you could just chalk it up.
Oh that's just camaraderie.
We needed that because of evolution.
That's how we stayed alive.
Like maybe,
maybe,
but maybe there's something else.
Maybe the whatever this consciousness is that's totally not,
no one is ever defined consciousness and there's certain people that think that
it occurs only in the brain and the neurons and the synapses and it might or
that might just be an antenna.
I mean consciousness might very well be you are using your physical tissue to
tune in to whatever this,
this thing that we share is this life force that we all seem to share.
And when you,
when this other thing,
it's like looking in someone's eyes,
man.
Like when you know someone's like there for you and you know you're there for
them.
Like that comradery,
that intense comradery,
this,
he's just like that,
that the expression,
the windows to the soul,
that the eyes are the windows to the soul.
It really does seem like that.
Right?
Like you see people,
you see them,
you know,
like the Avatar Lady said,
I see you.
Yeah.
Yeah,
you can.
It's,
I'm
looking at it didn't even really looking at Saint Mikes.
Alright.
You can tell a lot.
You can tell if they're bullshit.
Yes,
they're full of shit or not man.
Or if they feel weird about something,
maybe they feel like maybe this isn't a smart thing or maybe,
maybe,
maybe I should've done better by you or maybe I fucked you over.
Yeah.
You could tell that.
And I,
uh,
I,
I turned the first,
first time I had the,
uh,
open heart surgery and line three times during that surgery,
I also had an experience.
Um,
that also strengthens my belief.
And there being something after the body dies,
I,
or Asian or whatever you want to call it.
Uh,
okay.
Which I see.
I was able to see my mother who had passed away the year before.
And uh,
you know,
I say I see my mother,
I see her face.
I just heard a voice and I knew it was her and she was,
um,
you know,
pleading to a,
I say guide.
A lot of people may say,
you know what?
Whatever they look up to and I ain't got no problem with that.
I don't think that,
uh,
because people don't believe exactly like,
I believe that they're doom and they're going to hell.
Although that was the way I was raised,
or if you don't believe right,
this all Catholics went up when I quote them,
my dad,
all Catholics for this lost,
they're not gonna make it because they don't believe they believe the wrong
chair.
Ain't that fucked down bleed,
right.
Shifter.
So of course they're not going to make it about Jews.
I'll go there.
They're not going to make it live yet in that you don't believe like this is
fucked up.
Oh,
just lost man.
Fuck off man.
Your cytologists Oh specially your especially lost and that's,
you know,
but that's,
yeah,
that's how they felt.
That's how I was taught mysteries and I just,
you know,
I don't believe that you got,
you got this.
My Dad was some people,
the problem with that thought that he could walk on water,
he could do no wrong and it's the same guy that,
you know,
steal,
break my notes and send me through the fucking emergency room,
keep mine.
And my mom was a slave and that was perfectly fine with him.
And also this was the guy who was fucking women in the church.
But you don't believe like,
I believe you're going to hell.
Yeah.
People have a remarkable ability to be hypocrites.
Yeah,
there's soup.
And I seen that so much from super religious people.
They just turned me off from being a religious purse.
Well I think a lot of what it is is control.
People want to control other people.
They want to be able to tell people what to do and when to do it.
And it gives them some power in their own life by doing so.
Yeah.
And Man,
I,
I just,
uh,
you know it,
these stories,
my,
uh,
um,
faith and just super,
you know,
people that are in church every Sunday,
every time we went to church three times a week,
three times or eight times every Tuesday,
every Friday and every Sunday in church and churches.
I mean,
during the watts riots,
I'm a little kid.
We went to church.
Wow.
Yeah.
The guy that soldiers and national guard on the streets,
they pulled my dad over.
I'm a little kid in the back seat.
Where are you going?
Uh,
I'm going to church and I'm like,
fuck these guys.
There's tanks on the street.
This guy has got fucking MCS 16 and asked him and my dad's like,
we're going to church.
And I'm like,
fuck,
could you leave us at home?
Cause my brother Mike,
can we leave?
I want to be at home looking at fucking Heco in Japanese cartoons,
man.
I don't fucking be ID.
That got man,
we went to church,
man.
So he was super dedicated,
you know,
to,
part of it was super dedicated to what he believed.
And then,
um,
you know,
you go over the sisters Sally's house to give her consultation and I'm looking
in the room,
her bedroom doors open and there's my dad with his fucking tee shirt on,
sister Sally's in her slip and shit.
And I guess me and my brother were there to be as a scape goat or,
you know,
he's,
excuse my mom,
you know,
if I take them and you know,
nothing could be going on wrong,
where am I still remember that shit?
Fuck.
What kind of castle tasting is he doing?